thank you for coming on the tonight
where they offer you things no but I
think they're kidding I think all of you
know me but I'm deaf issue Yoshida and
director the program negotiation and
conflict resolution and I let our other
esteemed panel members let's reduce
themselves robert anderson i teach the
course itself is instrument and i'm
jenny bitch
i teach advanced creation what i do
notice in the audience program even
though you still probably don't know
each other a lot of you because some of
you have already graduated some of you
have come in at different time so it'd
be a really good opportunity to network
with each other and if you get people
who are also non NEC are people and part
of what we'll be talking about is
networking but that role plays in career
development so one of the reasons why we
wanted to have this evening is because
we realize that unless you're in a
situation where people are walking
around with machetes and machine guns
and there's obvious conflict people
don't get what we do in this program and
how you can use the skills and the
concepts that you learn here in the real
world so we want you to do is give you
some ideas about how we use this
information when we try to work with
clients in different places and
organizations communities mediation
centers and so on and then maybe we can
learn from each other in that process
some of you may already be doing some of
the things as saying some of the things
we're already saying and maybe not maybe
you'll pick up some tips but how to
frame what you're doing in a way I was
talking to you somebody who does a lot
of career development and he was saying
that knowing how to target and have to
pitch what you're doing to the right
target audience is critical in being
able to do good career development so
that's part of what gonna be talking
about today so the goal is that first
Jenni then Robert then I will say a few
words and then we'll open it up for Q&A
and discussion so it could be a dialogue
we don't have to be the only people with
expertise in the room other if you have
expertise in the room so athletes
everybody do this going to a dialogue
and that would be fine
okay again I'm Jenny Veche and I teach
advanced mediation in the program and
I'm really thrilled to see how many
people are here though I'm worried that
that just means that the ranks of the
unemployed is growing but let me tell
you a little bit about Who I am and what
I do and why I do it and how long I've
been doing it and then how what I do is
applicable to other areas I come to this
world of mediation via the theater so
for those of you that are saying I don't
know transition change my life do it
something different I think it's all
completely possible I did it and right
now I run a mediation Center in New York
State the unified court system under
writes a program called the community
dispute resolution centers program and
it provides for a mediation center in
every county in in the state of New York
there's 62 counties but some of us run
centers that bridge more than one County
I - the Westchester and Rockland
mediation center so I have two counties
all of the 62 counties have a mediation
center that they can access and the
mediation centers are designed to prop
to provide alternative dispute
resolution through the courts and also
through self referral referral from
other not-for-profits government
agencies we also engage in teaching and
training mediators and it's a very broad
program and and each community dispute
resolution Center has different programs
so I'm just going to tell you about the
nature of the programs that I have we
have a community mediation program which
does mediation in the courts and on a
self-refer basis quality of life issues
noise issues consume
merchants landlord-tenant new dogs and
apartments that there's no dog allowed
that kind of thing we have an eviction
prevention program where we assist
people who are capable of capturing
future rents but have fallen behind we
work with them and their landlords to
get them back on track and agencies that
will provide funding so long as they can
evidence that they can carry forward we
do a family court mediation program
where we provide custody visitation
mediation for people in the Family Court
and that may be people who have children
together but have never been married so
they wouldn't be going through divorce
because there is no marriage - to take
apart but they still have family and
they need to address the issues that are
pertinent to the family we do divorce
mediation as well and we have a
restorative justice program where we
deal with matters involving criminal
justice and mediating those cases so
that people can really access justice in
a sense of the victim in a in a regular
court case
the victim is simply a witness for the
state for the most part unless it's a
civil suit right so if something happens
to you you've been mugged you've been
robbed you've been raped you've been
anything you are have been reduced to a
witness for the state the state is
considered the injured party and what
restorative justice a victim offender
mediation does is it returns some power
to the victim and allows them to enter
into a dialogue to really express what
has harmed them so it's a very
interesting area all of our areas are
fascinating but these specialty areas
seem to attract the most attention and I
can understand why so that that's the
the breadth of what we do with the
mediation center in addition we do a
great deal of training and the training
isn't always directed at people who want
to be mediators just for an example
tomorrow I'm going to be doing a CLE
program it's continuing legal education
we're at pace lost parenting plan
training for divorced mediators people
who really work with people generally in
advocacy an adversarial fashion but also
to take into consideration the kinds of
things that will return to us when that
agreement starts to fall apart and that
is the parenting plan and it's a really
interesting dynamic to be working with
attorneys and in this area because it
means that I and they have to shift the
way we think about one another and about
the context of them of the material so
it's it's been challenging I've done
some of this before and it's and it's
always challenging and I'm looking
forward to doing it again but the world
of mediation isn't just mediation it has
resonance for the legal profession and
for many other professions and in fact
you see an awful lot of attorneys coming
in to take training in mediation in part
because they see it's a new revenue
stream but also because I think a lot of
attorneys feel as though that kind of
had it with all of the adversarial stuff
and and I have some attorneys who refer
to themselves as recovering attorneys
but and some of them make brilliant
mediators so it's not that that if you
aren't trained originally in this and it
is in your you don't have to be a
certain kind of person in in your core
you have to be willing to expand your
core and that's what I think this this
mediation helps people to do and and
similarly it you don't need to use
mediation just as a mediator you might
use the skills you learn in mediation in
a host of areas and that's sort of the
bridge onto what we're we're taking you
across right now which is so how do I
use this stuff it's great I'm taking
this course and but what do I do with it
I just had a woman today actually called
me up to try to figure out what should I
take mediation training because I want
to make a career move and so how do I do
that
and can I make a living as a mediator
there are certainly people who make a
living as a mediator many of them have
law degrees many of them are either
attached to the financial world and so
they can bring some marry some of those
things together but you don't have to be
any of those things and you don't have
to mediate to use the mediated skills
these skills are used in all sorts of
businesses the most important skill to
me is being able to listen affect and
that skill is useful just about
everywhere in terms of working with
other people especially when conflict
arises and I can't think of a single
business in which conflict doesn't come
to the table and how you approach the
conflict is critical so mediated skills
of asking valuable informative questions
being able to listen and understand the
conflict from somebody else's point of
view that is so valuable in human
resource management for those of you
that have been in that or would like to
be in that I think you certainly didn't
apply that to that if you're in a
managerial position or would like to be
in a managerial position in any field
working with staff to have to build
their investment in the work that you
have at hand is the key and so if you if
you use these skills and and the notions
that are underwriting mediation and
conflict resolution you're going to find
its application is almost everywhere I
don't know if any of you were in the
healthcare field but I I'm in the
process of teaching a course with Sarah
Lawrence about mediation in health care
boy do they need it and you'd be
surprised how valuable it can be not
just from the administrative point of
view but helping doctors and nurses and
nurses aides work more effectively with
one another
with the patient's with the patient's
families using all of these tools to
form a more productive dialogue because
that's essentially what mediation does
it helps you form a productive dialogue
and as far as how you can use some of
these skills in getting a job I have
this instance with a young man that I we
walk our dogs late at night that's the
only way I know him except that we'd be
when you walk your dog at 11 o'clock at
night in the park we you become very
friendly with one another and and he
said to me was going for a new job he's
an IT person and he said I and he's
Japanese and so he's always worried
about that he's native Japanese and so
his language skills are not a hundred
percent so he's always nervous about the
job interview and he said to me what do
I say to them what do I say and I said
well are you a good listener
do you think you're a good listener
because he's listening to me and running
here Wednesday and I I said I think if
you can share that with them that that's
something you hold as important it's not
just whether you can do it but whether
you value it and he got the job I don't
think that's the only reason he got the
job but he certainly didn't blow his
opportunity by not being able to express
himself well enough and he had a
challenge because English is not his
native language and that can be a
challenge for people so understanding
what is valuable to the person listening
to you at a job interview what what are
they and using the kinds of tools that
we have in mediation to express yourself
clearly to them
that's so important and to make it
relevant to the kinds of things that
that they're interested in you have to
think about that connection and and
understand that they may not use all the
same language that we use in the program
reflective listening speaking from the
eye
they're not gonna listen to that but if
you can understand what's important to
them and what are those key things our
communication listening being willing to
hear another point of view all of those
things make you a very attractive
candidate and I think some of those
skills at least I hope so are the skills
that we try and foster in the mediation
component of this program so I said I
would talk for 10 minutes not just did
exactly that so I'm gonna stop talking
now okay
I'm Robert Anderson and I teach the
self-assessment instrument course and
what I thought I would talk a little bit
about this evening is sort of what I do
sometimes people say you know what do
you do how do you do it and then I want
to talk a little bit about the process
of how I got to where I am because I
think for many of you it's kind of you
maybe have a vision in mind but you're
not quite sure how to get there and I've
learned a few things along the way that
were useful for me I don't know if
though this would be useful for you but
I thought I would share them and then
you can make up your own mind so I'm an
independent trainer and consultant I
have a small training company it's
called McDonald Anderson and I've worked
in I've had the company for about 20
years now I the way that I got into
conflict was first of all I got my
degree in adult learning at Teachers
College before I started my company and
and also before I can started my company
I took a course in conflict resolution
at Teachers College it was the basic
practicum which I sure many of you've
heard of it's very similar to what we do
here in UCR and so one of my main focus
is training so conflict resolution
training negotiation skills became one
of the things that I offered the clients
and I was coming at that point on a
Citigroup I was a training manager of
the Citigroup and so what I did is I
added it to my pack
of skills of different things that I
offer so now the things that relate to
kind of what you do I do courses on
things like listening skills conflict
resolution negotiation skills different
kinds of communication training
assertiveness skills and what I do is I
do it internationally my goal had always
been to work my goal was always when I
was a kid I always had this dream that
someday I was going to do education and
I was going to somehow do it in the
world
and I've been able to do it somehow and
it's been it's been really great so let
me say look let me talk to you a little
bit about kind of the process that I use
because I think this is this is
something that up that I learned this is
like 25 years ago I read this book yes
it's called what color is your parachute
you know that book they talk about
informational interviewing and then I
read another book where they talk about
planned happenstance does anybody would
have planned and happenstance oh good
it's doing something new it's kind of a
it's a it's an oxymoron right planned
happenstance the idea is that the way
the world is today it's very hard to
have a linear idea of what your career
is going to be because you plan for your
career and you said no in these many
years that I'm going to get to this but
what happens is by the time you get
there the world has changed so this guy
his name is Johnny
John crumbles says that what we have to
focus is on what he calls planned
happenstance so we still need the plan
but we need to be aware of the
opportunities that are emerging all
around us and the implications for that
is that we need to have net we need to
be in networks of people who are doing
the kinds of things that we like to do
and so that was a really strong message
for me 25 years ago when I started my
kind of my networking as I was leaving
Teachers College at that time I was
working in a non-profit we're going to
doing training and needs like Puerto
Rican and Hispanic community here in New
York and my idea was that I wanted to do
kind of international training with the
UN and or with some other organization
like that where I could kind of do what
I was doing locally and do it kind of
internationally so I read the book and
it said do informational interviews how
many have heard of the term
informational interviews okay so most of
you heard it but the whole idea run
informational interview is you try to
meet the people who are doing what you
want to do so you call them up now I
guess you can use you can use email but
calling is even better because it's hard
for people to say no when you have them
on the phone if you can catch them on
the phone and what you do is you say
so-and-so suggested that I give you a
call because I'm really at that point my
goal was I'm really interested in doing
training in Latin America and I know
that your company does training in Latin
America and someone told me that you
would be a good person to talk to so you
get an appointment in person and then
you interview them and you always ask
for 15 minutes of their this is straight
from the book it's like the rules of
informational interview
straight for booking it so I would you
know I do what people tell me I follow
the rules yes I I went and I came you
know these questions and actually the
first person was somebody referred by my
professor and he happened to be the HR
manager of a bank in New York and I
called him up and I was like really
scared and I called him up and he said
to talk to you so I went one day at 8:00
in the morning before my job I talked to
him for 15 minutes he told me about what
they were doing in Latin America and and
then I said that you're supposed to say
is there anybody else I should be
speaking to he gave me a list of three
other HR managers on three other banks
and so when I called up those new
managers what you do is you say John
Smith from this company suggested they
give me a give you a call so anyway they
hear John Smith and they go oh types of
influences so it's like you kind of you
person's name to connect with this other
person so what I did was I I went and I
you know I was really relentless with
this I think I set a goal of doing like
three a week and I did it for 15 weeks
so I did like 45 interviews where I went
around and I talked to all these people
she comes a little bit later
I didn't actually get a job but what
happened was there was a consulting
company that that sort of turned
teachers into trainers and they paid
very little but I was able to get a job
there and once I got there I knew all of
these people in the industry and I was
able to help them sell their services to
all these people who I met through my
informational interviews and then once I
was there for about a year I was able to
move to this Wall Street company and I
actually didn't like the Wall Street
company but I was there for three years
learning kind of how to do training in
an organization so then when I figured
well now that I know this I can do it
independently because what I really
wanted to do was over to work
internationally so I put my job and I
called up actually I said a fax in those
days you're training a manager in the
Tokyo office the Hitmen and I liked you
know the of the company where I used to
work and I said I'm coming to Tokyo and
I would really like to meet people who
you know maybe who would be willing to
maybe hire me at some point I'd like to
do something do some more informational
interviews so she said sure Oliver just
you just
the training managers here in health
care so what I did was I wanted an
actually she created there was like this
group of training managers and she had
me do a presentation on it was like
presentation skills so I've met all
these people and and then I went around
and talked to everyone and I found out
that they would be willing to hire me if
I would come to Japan they wouldn't pay
my way over but if I would come they
would hire me so and that's what I'm at
best this is like 20 years ago
Oh 1991 and so then then they since my
fields Adult Learning they had all these
people in the companies that they were
training matter to but they didn't
really know training there were more
like administrators so their group
decided into a training program to train
them to be trainers so I said they hired
me to do that program and I thought I'm
either gonna live or die in Tokyo
because they don't like the program I'll
never work again in this town but what
happened was they liked it and so what
what I began to do was every year I
would go to Tokyo three times and I
would continue this process wherever I
would meet someone I would like try to
get them to introduce me to other people
and what happens in Japan is everybody's
kind of connected to the rest of Asia in
those companies so like somebody gave me
the name of somebody in Hong Kong so I
went to Hong Kong I met that person and
I met other people and so wherever I go
it's like I always try to meet people
and I do the same thing but 15th why do
you have 15 minutes of your time I'd
like to just ask you some questions and
the interesting thing particularly when
you're starting out is when you do an
informational interview it's like and
you all kind of know how to listen so
this is really dangerous stuff with you
all because you're you kind of listen to
people and when people feel listened to
it's like they like you and you ask them
questions about their life and you know
how they made their decisions you're
getting a lot of useful information
about the industry or the
the field and you're also getting
somebody who points you and takes an
interest in you
so the thing that I think is really
important is after you did the
informational interview you have to send
a sake you know like people look good
but but people do it with me like I do
it all the time with good information
over and they don't think should thank
you notes it's like no you're not
following the rules thank you and then
we have to say to the person is there
anybody else I should be talking to if
you talk to any of those people you have
to get back to the original person and
say I talked to this person and I really
like that bubble up so what happens is
everybody is already in a network that
was the thing that was like dawned on me
which was I thought I had to create the
network but in fact everybody's already
network what do you have to do is get
into the network and once you make a
positive impression on someone they
start passing you around
you mean all these people and so what
I'm suggesting is what happens is you're
there kind of within the opportunity
structure of the people that you want to
be working with so when things come up
they say no I still haven't done any
training in Latin America but I was like
so theories of Japan and so it wasn't
where I what really wondered if
eventually I did get work with the UN
and I've done that worked in most many
of the countries of Latin America and so
it's kind of the processor that I always
use so if I wanna find that go to a new
country I like one the first time I went
to Japan I I told everybody I was going
to Japan and somebody the guy who owns
the florist on 86th Street he does he
does he retired he's not there anymore
he was actually friends with somebody
who was president of the Japanese
Marketing Association and he gave me his
name and introduced me and that that man
eventually got me worked in Tokyo as
well so there's a serendipitous aspect
to this so once you start pushing in a
certain direction
action this is kind of like an I guess
what I'm saying is that it's really
important to do this kind of
interviewing of people and you don't
necessarily know it's gonna get you
somewhere like we certainly apply for
jobs look for jobs but these are the
kinds of things that help you get sort
of into the hidden job market which is
kind of all around you because things
are evolving and changing all the time
so I think my 10 minutes now so I'll
back up before I met Robert now after so
my original career was in special
education I was a resource teacher who
knows they've done maybe they still have
resources now but work with kids with
learning behavior disorders I also as an
art major and so the reason I got to
Japan was because after I graduated in
school I was offered a job but it also
learned I went to school in Buffalo and
I did not want to stay in Buffalo so
there also you should always go to
school where you may want to work
because you meet people and network
there and I put notes I went to Europe I
traveled and I was studying art and
studying Japanese calligraphy and the
teacher said you want to go to Japan
look at the family teach English I said
well you know I should do something
serious with my life and then I was
snowed in on a horse farm I was living
for three days and I said what am I
doing here this is not what I want to do
went to Japan and I was teaching in the
international school system where I met
another colleague of ours Adair and the
first year I was there I just study art
and study calligraphy and teaching
English and living in a family and I
thought
I want to do something within my own
family why would I want to do that then
I ended up staying and I went to the
American Embassy and I looked up all the
international schools and I found some
and I met a dare and then she hired me
and for five years I was a resource
teacher in the international school
system and I became interested in
intercultural communication by a just by
that because we had international school
lots of different situations and many
times families that were having
difficulty would target the children as
the problem so that they wouldn't have
to deal with their marital issues so I
already called in to do an assessment on
children to see do they really have
learning problems or is it the parents
and then that's how I became involved
and what was called at that time the
Tokyo community counseling service I
worked with lots of different people on
a team and many people who had like by
cultural families were having issues as
well of course culture and that's how he
came involved in that came back to the
u.s. I've already got married and had
one child at the time and I want you to
make a transition into training and
development working in an organization I
was tired of working with children and I
was a little burnt out and then I wanted
to move up I mean you move up in k-12
education usually move up into
administration and I didn't want to do
that at the time so I went to see a
career counselor and she was preparing
me giving me some assessments you know
this is what you can do and the range
was like from here till there you know
it's like all these different kinds of
things but it was very difficult re to
know that organization it's very
difficult to go from education to
business because people don't value in
general what you've done in education
even though I've created a room and it's
ittle bit and the researching the whole
function and all that so then I decided
and I got a job selling photo copiers
which gave me my business experience I
needed selling photocopy because
everybody hates their photo
and I transitioned into working in
training development working with
Japanese usually businessmen who are
coming overseas to do business and then
helping members across cultural aspects
and I got hired at McKinsey and company
management consulting firm to be a
training manager there and that's how I
met Robert the name of the group called
the training forum and it was for people
working in foreign affiliated companies
in Japan and HR and training and
development and so we would have guests
who would fly in it's always very
excited to fly into the place people
would live that you could be the most
talented person but I was well organized
that works yeah I know the training the
trainer and it was a make or break for
sure so then I'm in 1995 I came back to
the US and who did I know in New York so
Robert was my network Robert was my node
my hub right
so I said Robert I'm here and I started
that I didn't want to go into an
organization to work because most of the
work was admin I don't want to do admin
I went to be there working with people
he introduced me to our colleague and
you went so then I started doing
trainings on the UN I met people who are
working at the I triple CR and that's
how I came in to Columbia University and
very kind of sidetracked but the reason
I got to the UN also is when I was at
McKinsey I was doing a lot of
intercultural work a lot of work with
conflict leadership development teams
multicultural teams and negotiation and
that's why I made that transition and I
always say I've been in the field 25
years in conflict all my life so I know
about I'm like especially a New York
independent woman going to Japan in
those days first time I went was like a
long time ago so then I started to build
my company from nothing so I just came
back here I didn't have in there
or I also joined a doctoral program
there's some kind of stress scale I was
like way overboard on the stress scale I
just bought a house I had separated from
my husband it's just like all these
different things happening was but I was
focused so that I sort of building my
network and building my consulting
company and also doing training and
teaching at the our triple CR and so the
critical thing there is yes networking
is everything I've never gotten a job
coal coal I don't think ever everything
is who you know and then it's what you
know so you always happen to me and you
never know when people will come into
your life because it's kind of like a
spiral and you go around and then
suddenly that person who you knew back
then comes back second be careful you
can talk about people because you never
know who knows somebody else you start
to say something like oh yes great
person you know anyway so then I started
building my business there and oh and
the things I learned from special ed
that come into play here is like they're
about being able to break things down
into its smallest components because
when you do different kinds of tasks
with kids who have learning issues you
have to give one direction at a time you
can't give multiple directions also when
you ask a question you can't do that
machine rapid-fire where you ask several
questions and they don't ever get a
chance to answer that overwhelms people
yet there's one question at a time so
then how do I take all this into
consideration so I have intercultural
communication in my doctor work I
learned about transformative learning
which is the adult development that
Robert talked about as well I started
learning more and more about negotiation
and conflict resolution and then in my
doctoral work I also learned about CNN
coordinated management of meeting and I
use all of these things together all
four areas together interconnected when
I go into an organization I don't say
all the time to conflict resolution
because they are we going to accomplish
them I think yeah you probably have any
disagreements or things like that so
when I go in also from an organization
development point of view how do I get
people in the room together who have
different points of view how do I get
them to listen to each other to
facilitate that process to get there
from here to there so at the end of the
day they feel they've accomplished
something at least if they come to some
agreement or not they hurt each other to
some degree all of those kinds of skills
that jenni arrival were talking about
with me
coming over and over again the other
thing you learned that it's very unique
is that you learn how to listen for
needs you do different kinds of
activities like three-part listening how
do you separate the positions from the
knees I cannot tell you how critical
that is because even people say yeah
yeah I'm listening they're not listening
the way you know how to listen they're
not listening for the needs so I can go
in and somebody's telling me about
whatever it is in my coaching situation
or maybe in a client intake situation
but I'm listening in a different way
than other people might listen to them
so I can pull out the knees and then I
paraphrase the family yeah you know and
then as always said something brilliant
but I did all I did was respect that but
they years ago I met somebody in the
kids who did then became training to go
in the manager what director I should
say at Goldman Sachs downtown we went
out for lunch one day and he was a very
good guy and did a lot of coaching he
said you know bets when consultants come
and talk to me if they don't ask me any
questions I don't want to talk to them
and I had thought earlier I have to know
the answers how can I ask questions if I
ask questions then they gonna think well
what am i telling her she should know
the answers so then he said they have to
ask me questions but there's no way they
can know about my company and I said you
know you have a good point I don't know
about your company but I do know what I
know about certain kinds of skills and
those things so you ask the questions
kind of like the informational interview
they're asking questions to get
information and what you're doing is or
what I do is you take that information
and go through your brain like quickly
trying to figure out what do I know that
fits what this person is telling me
about what this person needs what story
can I relate about some other project
I've done what question can I ask to
build on what he's saying so I'm always
trying to figure out how can i connect
to continue the conversation but you
want to build and you don't want it to
be loose you want the conversation to go
in a certain direction
ideally they realize they're so valuable
they want to hire me to come in and do
something doesn't always work but you
build the network and you do ask people
what do you know another thing that
happened to me once was I knew somebody
from Japan doing
back here everyone so I would get
together and have lunch and I didn't ask
her for a job I didn't ask her for
consulting work but I said you know
anybody and she had referred me to other
people and the one day were talking so
she that's what are you up to so I just
I was saying whatever I was up to she
said listen why don't you send me a
proposal I never expected to do
something with it but she had worked for
St Lauder at the time and I ended up
doing some development program for her I
think it was a Singapore thing same work
my first trip to Singapore then so you
never know what's going to happen so you
talk to people you connect people
another tip people have said to me is
when you meet somebody you always want
to have a way of coming back and there's
a fine line between stalking networking
and saying except you want to stay on
their radar screen it's not that people
don't want to be in touch with you but
they forget about jokes they get busy so
you want to come back there's no set
time like every three weeks you don't do
that but if you have we see an article
or you've reads about something I hear
about something that connects to
something that that person had said it's
a head thought this might be of interest
to you and there's a way it's staying on
their radar screen all the time in that
sense I do a lot of work with teens
because as you know anybody's ever
worked in a team or group project right
there's always something that's going on
people just don't do it your way they
just don't listen to you right so how do
you get into a team and help them work
together more effectively more people
are being asked to do more with less how
does that work so all of those skills
and all of that goes into the topics
that we're talking about most of us do
our work in organizations we also do
work in communities community mediation
centers I've worked with ported it in
different kind of towns in New Jersey
I've gone in and I've helped people
there facilitating forums because you
had a lot of angry parents thinking that
their kids weren't learning that the
right way there was a math wars and they
called it the math Wars and the lovely
thing about the Internet is everything
was
the Internet and then I was on the
antenna or were they talking about me
for so run these forms of writing a
report and being a facilitator and also
warnings was coaching a principal who
would had a vote of no-confidence and I
thought how did she have the courage to
get up every morning go back into that
school and all of the faculty is voted
faculty voted no confidence they didn't
believe in her and she man I coach took
her a year and she managed to stay that
the two or three more years and then she
retired so that was you know breaking to
do quit these skills it wasn't only
about confidence how does she
communicate with her staff how did she
gave herself a fill about engagement and
motivation one other thing I want to
mention is the whole idea about
performance management most systems have
formal performance management reviews
performance appraisal but the informal
conversations that don't take place but
should or where people get into a lot of
problems with employees and managers and
organizations and why do managers not do
it they just don't know how they don't
feel comfortable they don't stay
especially if they expect that the
person's going to be emotional like one
of the worst things you can do sometimes
is cry and you just feel oh my god we
had two managers at McKinsey one guy was
too sensitive and half a guy and then
there was the other guy the empathic
things that if I had the box of tissues
in your a moment and the other guy had a
roll of 20 music here wipe your eyes
father why do you do performance
management workshops with people so
employees know how to ask for support
from their managers and manage
no had to ask him give feedback
constructive feedback without getting
the big emotional overlay to it so all
these skills go into that but we're
going to be empathetic passing the right
kinds of questions and not just asking
questions to keep somebody boring
but really ask questions that get you
the information that you need that you
can build on to go to the next step now
we've opened it up I'd love you to ask
questions make comments
give some advice and tips about things
that you may have done that have worked
in you or things that don't work not to
do
Oh
everybody's not the kind of things feel
otherwise will be like walking like
robots and it's like the 30-second
elevator pitch
we learned to send Mackenzie they said
you're welcome to the elevator you go
into the client and suddenly just people
the door closes the CEO walks in
freezing and he says how's it going to
really be able to say something
sometimes did you want to well one thing
I I would stress is that you help people
work together more effectively because
that's really what you're doing whether
you're as a manager or as part of a team
it's the bigger picture of working
together more effectively because one of
most businesses want they want you to
produce but you can't produce unless the
team works together effectively or
individuals work more effectively so
that's certainly something that that
conflict resolution brings I think you
made a point that really hits home
because we were trying at my Center to
do some more corporate work because we
figure that's where the money was and
and we went to a company and talk to
them about conflict resolution now this
is a big company they couldn't stand the
word conflict to them that's a negative
whereas more productive processes more
productive communication seems a
positive so if you can frame what it is
you're providing or would like to
provide in a positive when you mention
everybody fights that sounds negative to
them but if you say I help people become
the best that they can be or I can help
teams work more effectively that looks
like a positive and I think providing a
positive outlook is something that
people can link to because they don't
really like to think that there's
something wrong where they're working
even though there always is yeah for me
it's like there's two different kinds of
elevators speeches and I know some
people don't like the elevator pitch
even calling it that but I think you do
need to be able to say something about
yourself so people remember who you are
and what you do and
so on the one hand if I'm sort of
marketing myself I say I have a small
training company and I focus on
communication conflict with those or
blah blah blah or those are like people
in HR whatever but when I was starting
out it was more about an informational
interview you're really trying to find
where you're gonna you're trying to find
your place so I think it's often to say
something like I've just completed my my
degree in conflict resolution at
Columbia University and I'm really
interested in working more effectively
and with organizations and using so
you're kind of like there's some kind of
statement where like there's giving
little pieces about yourself that kind
of give the kind of the credibility and
also kind of the unique things like when
I was starting off I was saying I'm
really looking my background is I was a
Spanish teacher and now I've been
working I've completed my degree in
adult learning and I'm really looking to
do training in Latin America so it was
kind of trying to put together the
different things that I had in a way
that would be interesting to people so
that what people would remember yeah
that's the guy that's interested in
training in Latin America so when you're
going to informational interview after
you've asked them questions you can say
to them given that I'm interested in
conflict resolution I really want to
work more effectively with organizations
I'm wondering what advice you would have
to me in terms of how I can market
myself so this is you're not so much
selling yourself you're more kind of
searching for your audience and you're
trying to connect with people and people
give you really good ideas so you're
you're not at that point an
informational interview you're not
trying to market yourself you're more
about trying to get information and
trying to connect with people so I think
having some kind of statement about what
you're looking for kind of what your
vision is what you don't want to do is
say I really don't know what I'm doing I
just graduate I really don't want doing
what I'm doing I'm just trying to get
some ideas from somebody because you
know like nobody wants to give
information to somebody like that they
want to feel like there's some kind of
plan here some kind of intention that's
that's that's meaningful in some way
that they can maybe be part of because
what you can find are really great
mentors this way and also as Beth and I
did we've now worked together for 20
years just because you know we connected
and you find people like that so you're
you're starting out so you need help
from some of the people that have been
doing it for a while that's that's how I
see it
and I would say something about people
helping people develop more
self-awareness about themselves and
others so they understand the impact
they have on others because that really
impacts the relationship so try to help
people like better quality relationships
and also have it in the larger context
facilitated collaborative processes but
it depends on who I'm talking to again
if I use that terminology or not so I
think a good thing to build on that
would be think about a cute a few key
points that you want to stress and just
make sure those are the key points you
say and just put it together in the
little one or two sentences that would
be good then again it's targeted at who
you're talking to
something else yes that for those
interested international politics
international relations
how does framing in peace building be
statement versus not the disclosure list
of us between three and I'm interested
in knowing it you see a distinction
point people reply to it
yes I think there's a good ol answer so
I think that recently what's happening
is a lot this Orma buzz around
peacebuilding then there is an
uncomfortable revolution so you want to
hook people into a buzz that's where the
energy is where the funds are going and
that's the projects but I wouldn't only
say peace building or something like
that I'd say a little bit more about
that for example for me when I think
about peace building I'm thinking about
post-conflict situations where we're
trying to create infrastructure and
trying to create a new economy being a
little bit specific like that so that
there build capacity which is also a big
those are going to capacity for
sustainable peace so that whatever piece
they became they can sustain that growth
and change that's a little package in
there and I but I would say it's
networking organizations that do that
they do that kind of work and tangential
if they're a lot of people even like
regular organization suppliers
corporations have to go in and send
supplies into these kinds of areas they
need help being able to be on the ground
in those kind of environments so it's
not just a non-profit or the UN agencies
that are in there there are private
organizations trying to go in there as
well
I just want to say one thing sort of the
International is not my area of
expertise but in anything that you go
after in any area that you're interested
in going after I think it's very
important to do a little self assessment
as well where you say you ask yourself
these questions why is that area
interesting to me why do I want because
at some point that's going to need to be
raised up but it also remember when you
first came into this program and you
went to the informational interview one
of the things we talked about was how
much this program leans on self
knowledge self awareness so it isn't
just oh I just want a job but to
understand why you want that job what it
is who you are and how you can help
marry who you are to the opportunity
that's ahead of you whether it's
International whether it's local whether
it's not for profit whatever it is who
are you and what I ask yourself those
questions you're a very important
component in what it is you sell you are
the component to what it is yourself so
you if you want them to know you you
must know you can really I think when
when I started
with friends but then after my
internship last summer I started just
staying with what I did and I didn't
really use the word conflict anymore at
all
and I think it ended up giving like as
much Egypt people to understand if you
get ribbons like staying with conflict
once I got used to say what I did it
became kind of like my pitch and it
sound I sounded I think I knew what I
was doing
remember something about what you might
sit but what something you said do you
say well it's to say I'm a part of what
I did was doing those communities
through 11 capacity-building word and
working on community dialogue in really
tense situations
with residents and our confidence in the
government to plan a dialogue session
and I help them carry it out and just
begin this dialogue process so it will
change in a community and that I mean
that they don't just change it and as I
speak about that more I can tell by just
speaking more confident and what I
thought at least that's tangible so if
he's looking at it that's oh that's what
it looks like it even if you say
conflict resolution people don't get it
I need to say mediation people may not
get did you find that the ones that
weren't person were much different than
the ones over the phone yep because what
happens is when you see somebody in
person you see their environment
and they get an also a physical
impression of you I mean know you know
yourself if somebody calls you by phone
you don't remember them like the next
day you know it's a you actually you can
it's like a moment of meeting the person
and a real connecting with them so and
it doesn't take long it's just but but
really actually seeing the person that's
one of the nice things about Manhattan
is we're so packed in here you can see a
lot of people in a short period of time
did you find me I avoided the phone
interview I would I would usually just
use the phone to try to get 15 minutes
of the person's time and I would I was
sort of relentless like I would call and
leave a message and if they didn't call
back I would call back the next week and
and you know and I always say you know
leave the name John Smith suggest that I
give give you a call I have some
questions about about your business and
I would just keep keep asking until
finally the person said no I don't want
to talk to you but I think it's
sometimes it's hard for people you you
know you your isn't it's hard for people
pick up the phone but I think picking up
the phone as a direct way of trying to
get a personal interview with the person
again you're only asking for 15 minutes
usually people give you more time but
ask for 15 that's kind of what the rule
is so now in an email in the subject
heading I'll put down introduction from
somebody
instead of just a name on a telephone
your advice is actually really helpful
to what I am I just use that similarly
but I also think that can be helpful if
you volunteered certain organizations
mm-hmm like for instance I've got my job
recently by volunteering through the
Rotary Foundation and Rotaract and if
they're very easy they have a club on
campus here I personally partnered the
one that's the new rhetoric New York at
the United Nations but they are very
open to have anybody there but I'm not
asserting this one particularly but I
think that these are helpful and anybody
being in this group of your you're in it
with a lot of young college students but
there's also they're directly linked to
like Rotary International and
we're tired but they're also connected
to business so in addition to
volunteering what I always would do is
go into some kind of leadership position
take on responsibilities into these
organizations because then you get known
if you're a membership then you're
reaching out to all the membership doing
something so it means an effort but I
think all these organizations are
volunteer organizations and they need
people to do a volunteer role so get in
there do something and be done and just
kind of like the older people in an
organization you can just say you know
I'm getting started in my field whatever
you want to call it conflict resolution
or working with dialog I'm wondering if
do you know anybody who's doing that
kind of work and people open their they
don't have rolodexes anywhere what do
they have they open something and give
you names you know if they like you they
want you to meet they want to introduce
you and they want to help you
and I think that's one of the things
that's hard is that sometimes you feel
like well I've got my degree I have to
do it on my own and I don't think
anybody really does it on their own you
do it because people like you because
they want to help you and because they
think you have something to offer so you
need to get people that are kind of in
your in your corner supporting you you
know it's LinkedIn so I put something
out they wanted since somebody had met
in Singapore sir Oh Beth and then
responded to me so you just keep
building and connecting with people
I don't spit up and down but the
community forum when that started I even
drank that and it was really interesting
and that's where that Michael Britten
and it turned out he trains he does
trainings every job done with the agency
I interned with them in the Department
of Justice and so there was that link
there in like finding where this network
is and not knowing it's there and when
at the age and then so Michael Brisbane
would talk about me with my director and
then it's like building this support
that I'm not even really part of I don't
know what I'm doing there okay and then
just paying attention also to where you
are and learning about where you are
they had all these photos of in this
office Evans Justice in one of the four
th but I come to mention that to the
picture
so tell Mort that his picture was up
from the wall to do J I did you have to
tell best people you can talk to our
secretaries so if you get there five
minutes early start a conversation oh
it's going and it what can I do
why are you calling
well sometimes you really don't know so
you're questioning yourself it could be
that it was really just an insight
promotion when it gives you a second
chance if you think connect to that
person so you set yourself apart from
the larger crowd so it makes some sense
to do that
here much newer to this field my
question music well formulated
my conflicted about what I heard and I
could not
see myself working to help tobacco
companies or boys
the Pentagon before the Wall Street
firms affect the economy
I hope to
their God wouldn't use it they were
there
so what I'm asking is what is the
reality of employment possibilities in
organizations whether it's
would use these skills in way
I hope that people just reinforce my
impression in
conversation I've had with people
who are saying that in this era of
sequester these programs the first cut
in the era of austerity nonprofit
budgets over the first
I think I can respond a little bit to
that because I work in a not-for-profit
and so maybe some of what I have to say
will have resonance for you while it is
true that we face the daunting challenge
of cuts when I run the center that I I I
don't simply take the cut like a hit on
the chin I have to figure out a way to
keep my people employed so I look at
grants and I look at other opportunities
or ways to create fee-for-service
options it still remains it
not-for-profit so long as the money that
you make goes back into the organization
and provide services for people who
can't afford them for example I charge
people for divorce mediation I do it on
a sliding scale so I recognize that
people who are at the very lowest end of
the income bracket they'll pay us
twenty-five dollars an hour and and
that's fine with us but the reason I
charge people who make a great deal of
money somewhat more considerably more is
so that I'm able to provide those
services for twenty five dollars so I
wouldn't necessarily feel that in the
age of the sequester and the way the way
the economy has been going there's gonna
be no not-for-profits or they're gonna
be fewer opportunities I don't think
that's the case I think there will
always be the not-for-profit sector but
it will require some other kinds of
skills and maybe you can bring them you
sound like you did something very
innovative bringing something to your
school district well that's the kind of
thinking that is important in a
not-for-profit but you have to think of
yourself as an actor not a reactor so
how am I going to keep this stuff
for-profit alive how am I going to be
part of the team that keeps it dynamic
and relevant and it's not just waiting
for the world and its impact on you
but how you're gonna support the thing
that's important to you so I wouldn't be
so discouraged I would I would go ahead
and look for the kinds of organizations
that have meaning for you and start to
say to yourself well what can I bring to
the table that's useful for them what do
they need me for that I can bring am i
clever enough to figure out a way to
just get a fund a program funded or do I
want to learn how to do that and if so
then who do I need to talk to Allah what
Robert is saying to figure out how to
become part of that but first you have
to find out what are the organizations
that you really care about or you think
do the kind of work we do but I wouldn't
I wouldn't just throw up your hands and
despair because I don't think that's an
all true I think they'll their there'll
always be need and when there's a need
there are people who run organizations
to fill those need and they do it
because they care but they also do it
because they need to stay employed and
so I work very hard to keep every single
one of the people that work in my
organization employed they count too
it's not just who you serve but it's the
organization you must keep that
organization healthy in order for it to
continue to do its work well so don't
get discouraged just find out where you
want to go and then building on that I
think that like I say the nonprofit
sector is a very big sector and
oftentimes they have even more of a need
than say companies that can pay for a
lot of training they haven't had the
same kind of training so there are
opportunities where they you know
they're people working together in
organizations they have conflict they
they need the same kinds of
interventions and in some ways there's
even more opportunity there the the pay
is not as much but but there's there's
certainly opportunities there sometimes
you can have create little consortiums
because if one organization doesn't have
the funding or a school doesn't have the
funding to pay for this if you put
together consciously a couple of
different schools or organizations to
created one workshop or one an issue
that they could pool their resources
together the other thing for a while I
used to be nicknamed pro bono best
because sometimes I just don't want to
do these pro bono or and I've been
reduced rate so kind of like my own
sliding scale when I do coaching in an
organization that's a nonprofit I do it
much less much lower rate than I do for
a private corporation in terms of values
and ethics and all of that if you are
not comfortable with the organization
and their mission and the practices that
they're doing that I would say don't
work them but if there are places that
even if they you know if the
organization itself is kind of like not
necessarily doing something harmful but
individuals might be doing something
harmful in there then you have to figure
out if you can make an impact there or
not my experience is in general
organizations are really tough places to
work whatever organization this and
sometimes nonprofits are harder because
what I find is people who are working in
mission driven organizations have more
emotions and more passionate about what
they're doing and every little thing
becomes a much bigger deal whereas
people working for a financial
institution they know what the mission
is and they're not as emotionally
engaged and what the mission of that
organization is people need support and
people need help everywhere so that's
how I am doing to it and if I had to
work for it tobacco companies have been
exactly what company came to do which I
haven't had that situation yet I wonder
what I would do and if I'm working with
coaching somebody in an organization any
kind of organization there's always that
element that you might be coaching and
out of the organization if that
organization is not a good fit for them
too
so you have to figure out part of the
self awareness piece what are your
values in the filling organization meets
that or not if it doesn't I would say
don't do it so a lot of demand out there
but it's a matter of how do you go in
and fit an either in the right time in
the right place and say the right thing
to the right person and then it just
clicks that's all of those elements
together it's not it's not magic but
it's all like serendipity in some ways
planful serendipity maybe
anybody has had a full-time position
within a company for profit or
government entity that was as a conflict
resolution practitioner as we've spoken
about nonprofits people know I mean
personally okay anything you can talk
about in the for-profit or government or
anybody to get close to that does come
to resolution importantly notice well
there are people who do conflict
management systems so they work inside
Republic management system design that's
one element people do Ombuds work people
who do training development but it's not
only conflict resolution it's
communication skills and other things
but conflict and negotiation could be in
there as part of it also employee
relations I haven't done it but that's a
big function in most organizations
working out the conflicts between
supervisor and staff and between
different departments so that's another
big piece it's often it's not like
usually a formal mediation but it's like
conversations to try to you know work
through procedures
process right so my thing is creative
process advantage and costly
so I don't have been struggling with how
to use the conflict resolution and what
that means
we can stir up some conflicts that they
need to go and resolve it
really Democrat Michelle Casey skills
and then there's also the whole field of
education people do go into working in
education doing training development or
like for outside of an educational
system or doing it in K through 12
schools preschools different kinds of
games and activities people can use
generate all the little junior high
school middle school and high schools
universities and things like that people
do and some people from our program have
graduated and done that in different
settings our organization the
Westchester and Rockland mediation
centers for ten years were where the
agency that responded to the grant from
that was given to the schools many times
you'll have schools or government
entities that have the grant and then
they come to the not-for-profit and ask
them to deliver the service and we had a
huge school program we still have a pro
a program it's just not quite as big
because the ten year life of the grant
ran out and so somebody has to figure
out now another grant but that's the
education field all the way up is filled
with opportunities if you can if you are
creative enough to see what grants are
out there sometimes coming to an
organization with an idea is a great way
to get into that organization co-author
co-sponsor the grant
yeah yeah
if you want to become a consultant as a
conflict resolution consultant how do
you start if you wanted to develop a
program in curricula do you do you
develop something general and then you
pitch it to organizations if it's not
organization against if it's an issue
something that's a international issue
how do you go about it I'd like to find
out what it's needed so that you can
read exactly to what the issue is there
are different ways of working with
clients and some clients go very deep
meaning that they they really try to
understand what the need is and they try
to create a whole system to kind of deal
with the conflict within the
organization another way to do it is to
do training so you can do both together
but for example since I travel a lot and
I go lots of different laces I tend to
just focus on training so I'm really
focusing on individuals in the
organization and trying to help them
deal more effectively with conflict so
if somebody's asking me to do a more
in-depth project then I'm turning it
over to somebody like Beth or somebody
who does a more kind of they're really
looking at the organization itself and
how they're going to create a system to
help that organization manage conflict
more effectively so if you want to say
if you have an area of expertise so
let's say it's like financial
institutions right so you work with
financial institutions you then know
what goes on in the financial
institution so you're speaking from
somebody from the inside who knows the
industry and then you can go to somebody
else in a financial institution and say
I know for my you doing an informational
interview and you're building and
getting the situation there and saying I
know from my own experience these are
some of the issues that we're facing
yet people facing these and these are
the things I think that could really
help do that so you want to match the
conflict resolution skills to a
particular industry that you have
knowledge and expertise available then
it makes sense because people usually
say what do you know about my industry
and what do you know about my
organization you're right I may not know
all things about your organization but
I've worked in other organizations or
another one
in your industry and I know about that
and I'm just wondering if you have the
same kind of issues I wouldn't go in
there and saying I know about I know
you've got problems I wouldn't go in
there saying that but saying based on my
other experience I imagine this could be
a need that you may have international
development organizations one one of the
things that they need desperately is
this work especially when they're on the
ground and they need to interface or
they don't but they should interface
with other development organizations so
partly if it's people coming together
from different countries now you have
the whole multicultural intercultural
aspect of it if there are people flying
in to a place that they're not familiar
with oh that is really difficult
conditions the stress of that can add to
its you bring that into being able to
have your resources there when you need
them and they don't always arrive that
can be stressful how do you build that
in and managing stress so you want to
find out what it is that the buzzword of
the hook that they're dealing with and
you can address because the reality is a
lot of the skills we do can really be
applied to so many situations but what's
the the word that's going to hook them
if they have team issues and teams the
word or stress or trauma then you want
to hook into that but you don't know
that until you get that information but
you can ask about that if you're
familiar with the industry and familiar
with other organizations I also think a
good tool in any area that you're
looking for when you're starting to
explore opportunities and you want to
figure out how to get in up I say it's a
good opportunity to find a friend who
you respect and practice the information
gathering because that's critical people
I think they're happy to do
informational interviews but if you're
looking to sell them something then
you're doing something slightly
different so you have to you have to
have a lot more information hand
I would practice with somebody who you
trust you feel like you all have look we
talked about networks you have a network
pick one of your colleagues and say this
is the area I want to go in and let them
ask you some questions that you can't
answer and then you get those answers
for you and and the same thing is true
to use the informational format that
Robert talks about to inquire to learn
to get before you go for the job make
sure you have lots of information and
lots of questions
and so if I wouldn't just say oh I know
I want to go do that kind of thing you
want to do that kind of thing find out
everything you can about that thing and
then practice with something one of your
colleagues to see if you know everything
that they might you know ask of you and
when you don't then you go fill in those
gaps because people when they're having
people come in to offer them a program
and ideas something they're gonna have
to pay for they want to know you're
worth paying for so come in complete
knowing your business knowing something
about their business and feeling as
though you're prepared even if you don't
have the answer you prepared to Mull it
over and get back to them it's all of
those things that says to them she's
thinking she's awake she's not just
looking for a job you're not looking for
a job you're making a career change here
through this thing it's more than a job
a job you get at McDonald's here you're
making a change
and maybe the change you're making
yourself will impact the change you make
there and that's important to people
otherwise why hire somebody why bring
somebody in and let's just fill in a
little spot that's more you're looking
for more of you coming to this place so
another way of building information is
interning and when you're a student is
when you intern you can't really be an
intern when you're not a student so
while you're a student take advantage of
being an intern because then when people
get to know your work from the inside
they may offer it and may turn into a
job eventually and it does sometimes and
the internship experience then you can
say oh I have experience doing this can
also lead you into a different job
another thing is if there's somebody
who's doing work that you like to do and
you may get connected to them and maybe
ask if you can shadow them if you can
work with them just to observe what it
is they do and how they do it but
sometimes when you see the finished
product you don't know what the process
was and how they got there so you may be
able to shadow them another thing is if
you can't enter in a chatter maybe you
can volunteer in a particular
organization for a few months
say I'm really gonna see what their
volunteer program is and then by
volunteering and being inside of that
program and you're learning what they do
in the building network there as well
they may end up hiring you or they may
refer you somewhere else because once
you're known you're a known entity if
you're good then it's your advantage if
you're not then you gotta go somewhere
else but if you're good and they get to
see you then there take you less of a
gamble on you and then people like that
better than taking a gamble you know the
other thing this somebody just mentioned
this to me was actually Nora was telling
me that if you are on unemployment which
I hope you're not but if you are on
unemployment you're allowed to have a
certain length internship that allows
you it through the unemployment process
so long as you report the unemployment
process not to be actively searching for
work and get penalized for not actually
searching so you have to find out from
your local unemployment office but that
is a very useful time because if you are
transitioning and you are on
unemployment these kinds of internships
if you're not a student are availa you
are all students here but some of you
will graduate or have graduated from the
program
you're still trying to figure it out I
did hire two people our restorative
justice initiative began with a woman
coming to me and saying I want to do
something with criminal justice and
together we went to a training and I
just paid for her training that's all I
did I didn't pay her I didn't until she
started this program and then together
with this program established we went to
seek funding and I hired her to run the
program so it's not as though that can't
happen and that same thing is true with
my custody visitation coordinator she
started out volunteering for us to help
out because we needed an intern and she
was able to do it now the rules around
internship are a little bit more rigid
but there are opportunities if you're a
student and there's certainly
opportunities as well if you're on
unemployment so you should if you've any
of you find that you're going to be on
unemployment or on employment look into
that because it's it's a real plant
happens
and I was wondering within the broad
field of conflict resolution is there is
are there certain types of positions
that require that kind of I would say
that if you're going to be doing any
kind of needs assessment company
analysis sometimes they want that and
sometimes a monitoring evaluation
depends but if you only do in like Laura
quantitative studies and the doctoral
degree is good but I don't think it's
critical I think that having the right
skills in the right place unless I want
to teach in academia to want to teach in
a higher education setting than the real
doctorate degree is easier so I guess
thinking about when you first started
out what were some
I don't know confidence-building
techniques or pet dogs that you use
themself so you could comfortably and
confidently say I'm the right person for
this organization and this is why
without feeling like we were both
staying or selling something
really
what's one thing I did is that when I
was at home and I would make phone calls
to people I would always get dressed and
not be in my pajamas because I felt like
they knew they knew that I'm using my
pajamas but something about my voice
would sound different so I would
actually get dressed to do it not all
the time now I'm still in my pajamas
sometimes ok well at the beginning I
would always get dressed because I
wanted to get into that professional
mindset and I would join lots of
organizations and just keep networking I
joined the transition support group that
that really helped me a lot and that's
where I learned all of this stuff about
networking because one thing is to learn
it you know mentally but to actually do
it and then to have people say ok you
say I'm gonna meet with three people by
the next time we have a meeting and
people would kind of hold you to it
so that's the kind of thing you know
career organizations do it but I think
you can do it with your with your
colleagues you know if you're in kind of
a similar situation you can do with each
other to kind of just encourage each
other and and support each other in the
kinds of decisions that you're making
the people that you're meeting
volunteering organizations not selling
yourself but you're meeting people and
actually they're meeting people in doing
things you're selling yourself cause
they get it to see what you can do oh
it's so true because if you do work with
an organization and you do provide a
real service but that's the key you
can't just be there looking for what you
get you have to really be doing
something and if you're really
impressive to them even if they don't
have a job you'd be surprised at how
often somebody says listen there's this
job that's how I got my job as director
of the mediation center I was working at
another mediation center doing filing
and mentoring and anything I could do I
started out volunteering and then I
worked for $8 an hour and it wasn't all
that long ago so it wasn't that my mean
it was 15 years ago but it wasn't it
wasn't you know 30 years ago where heat
dolls now we're something there
it was pretty bad but but that director
saw my commitment to that process and to
the work so when this came up I didn't
see it
this job he said to me apply is how I
can and and I had to look of what I had
in my background that contributed and so
going back to that notion of it isn't
boasting it's telling the truth you have
skills and you just have to sit down and
take the time to say what are my skills
and how can i what what do I offer this
company why should they hire me and
because I need a job isn't the answer
right in what can I give them and and
you should i but i think i think your
informational interview piece is also a
tremendously valuable tool for
practicing for job interviews as well
because that gives you an opportunity to
be before someone in a way that engages
people that's what people you have to
stand out there interviewing 30 people
for this position you have to stand out
and and that process will help you learn
how to do that
so what's the force for that could
happen that I stay in the same place
that I am right now so there is no
nothing you can loose by going down and
starting they say no we want it to be
like a revolving door we sent one
student in and I noticed a comes in so
we could compile that list we're already
compiling a list about what alumni are
doing there is the internship there that
ac for sponsors every spring so those
are different ways of doing it but yes
we could so where are you interning
that's right so we should we should have
that on the list somewhere Tommy my
shuttle
yeah it is a good idea because I know
that when Dan ago said he worked for the
DOJ during last summer and they had a
good situation there was somebody named
Daniel who worked at FINRA in a good
situation and usually a lot of these
organizations take other kinds of
people's like more students but they
took a chance on a cop that was
delicious to visit who's pretty good and
the people who showed up did a good job
so it was like if there isn't anything
else we might bring this to close unless
somebody has something else to say
I'm still have time but if not we are
happy that you all came hope you found
this valuable if there are some ideas
you have and you want us to help you
with be happy to hear that I'm not no
say happy to do that I'm going here
there and if it works out well for us
we'll help you do them yes I said help
you do them not that we will do them but
anchors is also a good organization
student organization which the
representation here tonight but anchors
as a group as your student group can
also work with us to think about how we
can come together and do things maybe we
can have informational interview
practice sessions or maybe we can think
about putting together a big networking
information and networking session or
something like that I'm happy to help
you with that thank you
you